Now as Doctor Zelig says, the ABCs can be used intentionally to change
behavior. But, we should also be aware that the ABCs occur in our natural
environment. For example, let's say you're thirsty. This is a motivation, then
you see the refrigerator, which is the cue, and you grab a soda and drink it,
which is the behavior. Then your thirst is quenched. Annie had something tasty
to drink, which is the consequence. Because the consequence was positive, this
tells me that I'm more likely to go to the refrigerator and get a drink when
I'm thirsty. However, there's another way you can look at this. Let's take the
same scenario. First say you're thirsty, which is your motivation. You see the
refrigerator, which is your cue. So the behavior in this scenario is that you
grab milk and drink it. But it was sour milk. So the consequence in this
scenario is that you spit out the milk and it was really gross, it didn't
quench your thirst. So this is a negative consequence. Therefore, you're
going to be less likely to go back to the refrigerator and grab milk in the
future.